belarusian sprinter who refused orders
to return home early from the olympics
says she
is happy to be in safety in poland
christina timonovskaya arrived in warsaw
on wednesday
days after accusing belarusian officials
of trying to force her to fly home from
tokyo
she has said that she fears for her life
if she returns to belarus
after criticizing her team managers
poland has or
has offered the runner a humanitarian
visa
dw reporter magdalena gavin has been
speaking with christina
timonaskaya in warsaw
christina welcome in poland how are you
the whole world is following your story
how does it feel
thank you so now i feel myself really
good because i have support
from the whole world and the support
make me much stronger and
i'm here in poland and i feel myself
like in safety and
i'm happy to be here and your biggest
dream up for now when you're thinking
of what happened and of the future what
is your first
thought what you what are you dreaming
of now i'm dreaming to
continue my sport career because i'm 24
and i wanted to compete at the next
olympic games and maybe the next olympic
games so it's
it was like my big dream even before
this situation
and going back to what happened in tokyo
could you explain us once again
who threatened you how was the situation
when
you had the information that you have to
go back to belarus
who was it and what did he or she tell
to you
uh this is formation tell me our main
coach
from athletics and he say me that
someone decides that i should to go to
home
and it was not his this his decision
it was just decision from the minsk and
he just
should to say me and so to
the
we're speaking with dw reporter
magdalena gavanche who joins us from
warsaw welcome magdalena
how did she see
well she was quite calm and you could
feel that she is also a little bit
tired but on the same time very grateful
that she is now here and you know she
made the impression to feel
safe now in poland um but on the other
hand
also to being a little bit how can i say
a little bit
lost a little bit out of place and she
told us she is a little
shocked of what big
attention is being paid to um
her story okay so despite feeling safe
we do know the belarusian regime has
demonstrated that its reach
is long what a polish authority is
saying about her safety
while she is there
this is a very important question for
polish authorities and as she arrived
yesterday in the evening she
and didn't use their main exit which
everyone uses
while landing here on the european
warsaw but she was transferred to a
separate exit so
the media could not talk to her
yesterday and um the polish authorities
emphasized that it's very important to
give her safety and to support her also
in her sport career so
she has some offers
she got a housing offer from one of the
city
and also an offer to continue her career
all right so will that that's something
at least and it sounds as though poland
has
has uh has rolled out the red carpet for
her
well you know we are quite close
emotional
with the people in belarus since also
many poles
are still lived there so uh people
here and followed her story of course
and
she was welcome very warmly here
and people are still keeping finger
crossed for her and uh
well we don't know what happens next we
don't know where she's going to live we
just know she's waiting for her husband
who should arrive today in the evening
and she told us
they want to search for a job for him
and she wants to continue her career in
poland
thank you so much for joining us and
bringing us that dw reporter magdalena
grunch in warsaw
you